we teamed up with Verizon to create some
holiday memories tonight here at our et
holiday carnival we are going to show
you how we party ET style yes we are and
we're so excited because we've teamed up
with Verizon and we're gonna capture it
all on the Google pixel 3m and the new
pop that's not real this is real and it
is the et newsdesk get in here that's
that is a guy telling you it's crazy
then how cool is this poem it actually
sinks to my bigger phone so I can leave
it at home and I can slip this into my
clutch or hide it in a cute dress and
still stay connected all night I'll have
a cheer oh please oh my mom is texting
me she wants to know if I'm coming home
for Christmas I'm gonna finish this in a
big way
by taking a group selfie with the Google
pixel three that's it watch this warning
you I'm not in the shot I got you notice
I got you oh no I can do that everybody
smile here we got a wine
the Google pixel 3 and palm are
available exclusively from Verizon for
great holiday deals for everyone on your
list visit their website oh there we go
smile 1 2 3 alright so there's only one
thing left to do cap do you know what it
is the dunk tank you're going down
Knight you're going
[Applause]
[Applause]
okay I'm soaking wet how much Cheers yes
it's not warm out here guys and it is
not warming that dunk tank but you know
what we have captured lots of great
memories and that's the thing
[Music]